Hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Hi!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
It's the end of the week!
And today also is our 108th episode!
Thank you for joining us!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's Friday!
Friday time!
BAU BAU!
I actually just saw a Ruffian asking, what is this FUWAMOCO Morning?
Wow!
For Ruffians that are joining us for the first time!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
There's so many exciting things going on this week at Ruffians!
A lot of singing.
Are you ready, Moco-chan?
Well, you know with exciting stuff, there has to be a disappointing stuff.
No, there doesn't need to be.
Wait, wait, wait, Ruffians.
Let's get started with disappointing stuff.
That's how we're gonna start our Friday.
There's been another Perroccino.
I don't understand.
I know Pero has his little wings and stuff, but... He travels around a lot.
Yeah, how does he find so many Ruffians?
He has a knack for it, obviously.
Where was Pero spotted this time?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Pero's out in the wild now.
You know, just the other day he was over in LA at Anime Expo.
No bothering.
Ruffians are trying to steal the show from us.
But...
Now he's bothering prairie dogs out in the countryside!
Ruffians.
Prairie dogs.
Pero.
I guess Pero's bigger than a prairie dog.
Pero's not bigger than a Ruffian.
Yeah.
Prairie dog.
Pudding.
This one is similar.
You know, I guess he has to constantly be bothering somebody or something.
Maybe it looks like the Ruffians are next.
He's had his fill of the prairie dogs and now you're next Ruffian.
The look in his eyes is really quite hot.
Good luck, okay?
Good luck!
In these situations, have friends.
Pudding will save you.
It's your best friend, okay?
Always good to have some pudding with you, okay?
Yeah.
Also, you know, in case you get hungry too.
BAU BAU!
They became friends.
Ah!
Friends.
Interesting way to put it.
Yeah, that's the way to put it.
You know, friends.
My one friend ends up in the tummy.
Strange.
Yeah.
That was disappointing.
But!
Yeah!
Well, next thing wasn't disappointing.
Isn't disappointing.
Why?
It actually made me happy, Ruffians!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO!
We hit another big milestone together!
Yeah, yeah!
Why?
With FUWAMOCO, our cover of Kanae's Identity has hit 1 million views!
Yeah!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
You've been listening to it lots and lots and just showing us how much you love our music!
Thank you!
We're really so grateful to have a number of cover songs over 1 million.
1 million!
That's so many!
It's absolutely amazing!
Thank you!
I know!
I hope I get to release a lot of new cover songs and music soon!
So please look forward to it, okay?
Yeah, I really- I just can't believe it's been so long since our last release now, Moco-chan.
You know, time flies just when you're so busy with a bunch of different things going on.
Do you wanna hear more Ruffians?
Arigatou!
FUWAMOCO korekara ganbaru kara ne!
What's the next one?
That's what I wanna do too, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Of course!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We hope you want to hear us sing lots and lots more from here on too!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Arigatou!
You know, we released that friend.
If they're gonna hear the rest of that good tweet, I wonder if we should do something like that again maybe, Moco-chan?
I don't think the Ruffians will say no.
BAU BAU!
You know, like we mentioned, it's been a long time since FUWAMOCO, since we last released a song cover.
But!
If it's together with Advent, we actually have something brand new for you!
We just released an English version of I'm Right Free together with Advent over on the hololive official channel!
The English channel!
Ruffians!
Did you have a chance to listen to it?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
So good!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we're really so happy we're able to sing it all together with Advent.
Because it's a song that really means a lot to us.
I know we say that a lot!
But really, really.
It does!
You know, we remember being
Back in the cellar, listening to it, wondering if maybe we'd be up there on that big stage at fest one day.
I don't know.
To us, it's a song that both represents a lot of hope, but also equal uncertainty for us.
We just wanted to be out of the cell so badly.
I know, of course, the lyrics really resonate a lot with us.
So we hope that you'll feel the message of this song in English, too.
Yeah!
You know, because it's in English, I think the message can kind of reach you a little bit easier this time.
So, we're really happy.
And also, you know, you can find this cover on YouTube.
YouTube.
YouTube for now.
But!
Very shortly, it will be released on streaming services all across the place.
At midnight July 20th in your area.
So I think maybe a few more hours.
Maybe for Japan.
Just now!
Just now?
Just now.
Unless I'm being a little silly.
FUWAMOCO Please listen to our friends!
FUWAMOCO We're gonna make sure Mama Puppy knows too!
FUWAMOCO The Ruffians know already!
FUWAMOCO Mama Puppy keeps on asking, when can I listen to this repeat?
FUWAMOCO Now you can, Mama Puppy!
FUWAMOCO Yeah!
In 7 hours!
A little bit longer.
Really soon, right?
But you know, we hope that we can cheer you on with this song and that, you know, maybe we could listen a little bit closely and see just how hard we've worked to improve our singing.
Did you notice my favorite part?
I talked about it a bit with Nerissa.
Do you know this?
It's a bit different compared to the Japanese version.
I don't think the Ruffians probably know this.
You know this!
Really?
Thank you, Ruffians!
We know we're almost at our first year anniversary, but of course, Abyss just started our idol journey, so we hope that you'll continue to cheer us on lots and lots!
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy, my artwork is so cute!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I hope we can release more covers soon!
Right, the English versions are so nice, huh?
Yeah.
You know, the nice thing is that the message can reach you a little bit easier, so... It's extra special.
BAU BAU!
Well, I feel like we have a bit of a pattern.
Right, Moco-chan?
What do you mean?
Disappointing.
Happy.
We're on the disappointing part again.
Ruffians!
You know what?
There's been something bad that happened that's causing a little bit of a rift between us.
Yeah.
And Ruffians, no, it's not what happened during Chain Together yesterday, no?
No.
And, you know, FUWAMOCO, we always say that nothing would ever come between us.
But, yeah, there's been an accident.
Actually Ruffians, it happened the other day.
Moco-chan here!
She broke my bag.
Yeah.
You know, Moco-chan was drinking a water bottle from my bag.
And so I asked her to put it back into my bag and then... Somehow!
You just absolutely ruined the zipper!
No, it's not like that.
It's just destroyed now!
It's not like that.
You did it in like five seconds.
I wasn't drinking the water bottle in the bag.
No, if you were, then the zipper would still be alive.
How do you drink a water bottle in a bag?
No.
But not because Moco-chan just killed it!
Now I can only open up my bag just a little way!
So you know, it's really tricky getting anything slightly larger into it.
And more friends!
You know what?
Moco-chan!
This puppy here!
Huh?
Still gets upset, you know what I tell him?
No!
No, Moco-chan!
You can't put that in my bag!
It won't fit!
I don't remember.
You know, Moco-chan, you can put it in your own bag!
I don't remember, okay?
Yeah.
Don't get Stephen Great dog!
I remember.
I remember, too.
My bag is broken now.
Put it in your own bag, Moco-chan, okay?
But you didn't do anything!
I didn't do anything wrong, okay?
You know.
It just happened.
That's how it happens, okay?
You know, I was hoping I could fix it, but... The zipper teeth are broken.
It's all like... You know, and I thought maybe... Maybe Mane-chan might be able to fix it, but... I don't want to burden her with it, too.
What should we do?
Muffins.
Can you fix the muffins?
Can!
Moco-chan, that's not gonna fix it!
Back to cheap!
Maybe.
Can!
Moco-chan, you think that's gonna maybe kinda make the zipper slide a bit more?
Cause it's not.
BAU BAU!
I didn't mean to.
I drank the water bottle outside of the thing.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO-chan, maybe we'll just have to go shopping.
Along with the balls.
Yeah.
Bag and balls.
BAU BAU!
I forgive you, Moco-chan.
If anything, it's kind of impressive.
It wasn't my fault.
Yeah, and you didn't once ask me to fix it myself either.
I tried to fix it myself, I didn't say anything.
I thought you'd pass my bag back and be like, well, I broke it.
No!
I'm not unapologetic.
I'm just saying how it is.
Okay.
It's broken.
BAU BAU!
You know I go through this disappointment thing.
Now we have an exciting day!
Ruffians!
We got a brand new FUWAMOCO school!
Thank you so much to D&F Ridescream for the impactful journalism!
BAU BAU!
Well, this summer Nenechi is going to be having a special event at Tokyo Joypolis as part of their Kabuto Kuwagata Fureai no Moriyama!
We're so happy for her!
If you didn't know Nenechi, she loves Japanese dog beetles.
Do you know them?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah, and you know at the event you can get up and close with the beetles.
So, I kinda wanna check it out too.
Right!
Right, we think stag beetles are really cool.
Yeah!
We never, we never, you know, seen them or touched them.
Yeah.
We don't have them in the Northwest Passage though.
So, it makes sense.
But, for stories, can you really make them battle against each other?
You can battle them, right?
My stag beetle will be your stag beetle!
Like that kind of thing!
Why?
They're Pokemon.
That's what I was thinking.
They're like, bug Pokemon.
I don't know, what kind of sounds do they make, too?
I don't know.
Do they make a sound like a me-me-me-me-me?
No, it's like a... Like that?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know much about that.
Hissing sounds.
Hissing sounds?
Oh, I wanna hear that then.
That would be really scary!
I don't wanna battle against one.
Well, no matter the sound, they look really cute.
They do look cute.
Yeah.
Actually, we were recently talking to Shiori about them too.
I think she's kind of curious too, right?
Yeah.
We'd really like to get to know more about that.
Maybe together with Shiori and Nene-chi can teach us.
I don't know if Shiori's just interested in eating them.
Maybe.
I don't think Nenechi wants that.
I don't think so, no.
No.
BAU BAU!
Good luck, Nenechi!
Yeah!
Congratulations!
So exciting!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, Ruffians, we're already about halfway, a little bit more than that, to July.
July is officially summer.
And this summer...
It's the summer of Advent!
And our 3D debut is just right around the corner!
There's so many exciting things happening!
A big whole EN concert in New York City!
But you know, between all those exciting things going on, actually...
FUWAMOCO, we really want to be able to go to omatsuri, you know, a summertime festival, all together with Abyss!
You know, it'll be nice to be able to go all dressed up in yukata, you know, have kakigori, shaved ice, yakisoba.
See some taiko.
The drum performances.
Do some kingyo-sukui.
You know, the goldfish scooping.
Living so much fun all together!
It sounds nice, yeah!
You know, having some ramen and trying to open it all together.
Tama-ya!
Haba-e!
Ringo-wame!
Shateki!
Doing some shiori games too.
Shiori can win me some
Hi!
Or maybe Biboo.
Yeah.
Shiori can try, Biboo will finish the job.
Yeah!
You know, we really would like to have an All Night City episode experience together with them all.
But, I don't know, it's been so busy.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm a little bit worried that we might not be able to do it.
Yeah.
But, I think...
If I had to choose one summer activity out of it, then I would like to do fireworks with them.
Not the big ones, you know.
Just the tiny little ones.
The not scary ones.
The big ones are sort of scary to us demon dogs, you know.
Fluffy and fuzzy, but... I wanna make summer memories together during my Summer of Advent, too!
Right!
The sparklers!
Can you pull out those sparklers?
The little ones you hold, you know... They have the... The one that you hold and it has the... The end and then it folds and you... That one.
Yeah.
But you know, I think if it's fireworks, little fireworks, maybe we might be able to get something done together.
At least we'll do our best to get that one thing done.
Even if we can't make it to a festival.
And then you know, that way, we can put a nice end to the summer with Advent.
BAU BAU!
What do you want to do at the O-matsuri, Ruffians?
Gingyo-sukui.
I feel a bit bad for the fish.
You don't need to take it home, you're just going to scoop it up and then be like, there you go, Mr. Fish.
Back you go.
You want to eat.
Eat.
Not the gun.
You can eat all the time.
You eat everything.
Naminé.
Wait.
I want to drink Naminé all together.
Do you think Advent can find Naminé in the glass bottle in the Biboo?
I don't know.
I feel like Biboo would be confused.
I think Nerissa would open it and she'd be like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
It'd be like exploding all over the place.
Sounds accurate.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It's a great summer out there.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
Let's take a look at who's our Doggie of the Day today!
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Jack-chan!
Jack-chan is so proper!
It looks like Jack-chan is going to do accounting.
Yeah!
Accounting Jack-chan.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Like that.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
He's totally spoiled.
He doesn't need to work a job because he gets any treat or toy or outfit he wants.
Because he's Jackson!
I'm Jackson!
Yeah, I know.
It's because he's cute and he loves you that he won't let anything get in his way of cuddling and playing with you.
I go it for his walks too!
BAU BAU!
He has fuzzy ears like Papa Puppy.
Papa Puppy's a bit wild, right?
Yeah.
Wow, very fierce, Jackson.
Very fierce.
BAU BAU!
And it's summertime, so naturally, Ruffians, you're going out and checking out the summer sky, right?
Let's see where you've been walking around!
De-den!
The beach!
The summer sun!
Beautiful beach, huh?
A beach of all kinds.
As expected of summer.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like you're so brave, you know?
The beach is a bunch of people, then.
Maybe you know this is early, maybe it's cold, maybe they're not there yet.
Maybe it's still chilly hot.
Did you bring back a bunch of sand in your shoes?
That's always the best part, huh?
All the sand that comes home with you, huh?
Well, maybe, you know, you got some cool shells while you were there.
Saw some silly crows.
Yeah!
Yeah, but, you know.
Poke them with a stick.
But the best, the best memories, the best memories that you make there, that's your souvenir.
Yeah!
Not the sand.
Not the shells.
And the photo!
Yeah, the photo's a good souvenir.
Maybe...
You know, this is a souvenir too.
BAU BAU!
Nice beach walk.
Ruffians, why are you saying FUWAMOCO in a bathing suit?
At least imagine this Ruffian in a bathing suit.
Why?
FUWAMOCO didn't go on the beach walk a Ruffian did.
This Ruffian did.
Yeah.
We don't know if they went on the walk in a bathing suit.
Maybe they went for a swim too.
BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Morning FUWAMOCO!
You've been together your entire lives, but has working hololive and playing frustrating games together made you guys closer?
Has working together made you realize more of each other's faults?
How do you handle being together all the time?
Has it changed anything?
You know we spent 2000 years together.
I don't think anything's changed, Ruffians.
Yeah.
Yup.
I don't know.
We're FUWAMOCO.
We're pretty close.
We know our faults.
We know our strength, you know.
Moco-chan's kind of like this right now.
Okay, it's kind of over.
Yeah.
You know, I think it's just kind of the same.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Demon bond dog- Demon bond dog?
Demon dog bond is too strong.
Why?
Yeah, yeah.
It's just how it is.
Yeah, and I've been seeing us bicker quite a bit sometimes.
Yeah!
It's just how it goes.
Yeah, sometimes that's just the process, you know?
It's just the process.
Yeah.
Nothing changes.
I don't think it's changed.
Sometimes it's rougher than other times.
It's been a year but nothing's changed.
No.
This is how it is.
But we feel very lucky, you know, Ruffians, because I think there's not many siblings, not even many twins, that have a bone like us.
No.
So we're very lucky, like Moco-chan.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, I don't think it's a normal sibling thing.
Not very common, no.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, we have another stream coming up
Well, we have that.
It's been about three months.
All of a sudden, two months.
Maybe three months.
It feels like three months.
Maybe that's two months.
It's been way too long!
Way too long!
But it's back now!
Back!
And we're gonna be singing some anime songs!
Some of our favorites.
There's too many favorites.
Yeah, maybe some surprising ones too.
So we hope that you're ready to BAU BAU lolololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololololol
And then we take a look at our schedule.
We have the Rock n' Rawr Party coming up very shortly.
But then on Saturday, FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be in Sydney for a smash!
We're gonna be talking with some Ruffians at a fan meeting.
And then later we have a mini Rock n' Rawr Party and Q&A.
So we're gonna be able to answer some Australian Ruffians' questions.
Australian questions, me.
Please join us on GAMBLERFEST!
You know, maybe you happen to be in the area.
Right.
Please come see us, okay?
BAU BAU!
And then on Sunday, we're gonna get violent!
Violent!
Because it's Advent versus Justice in Party Animals!
There's no question about it, we're gonna win.
We're gonna win.
Easy.
Yeah.
And Moco-chan will be playing, and Fuwawa will be playing.
So that means it's five versus four.
There's no question about it.
I don't know what they're thinking.
Have you seen
You know, Fuwawa play team together.
We're gonna win.
Yeah.
I'm a bit unpredictable, Ruffians.
You better watch out.
Never know where she's gonna jump off.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
And for the Ruffians who are joining us today through the archive!
Here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU Kuwagata!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning.
And for, you know, waking up early this entire week to spend it with us.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Melody!
BAU BAU!
Idol!
That's an interesting Ruffian name.
Angry Humper!
BAU BAU!
Snake Order!
Bukou!
BAU BAU!
Bakusou!
Weehee!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!